there's only two ways to get out of the
Gaza Strip there's the north border
crossing which goes into Israel and then
there's the southern Crossing that goes
into Egypt since hamas's attacks Israel
has closed this northern border leaving
the Crossing with Egypt as the only way
out but Egypt doesn't want to let
Palestinians in the country is not
interested in housing a bunch of
refugees from Gaza and they're worried
that because Israel is planning to
invade the Gaza Strip if these
Palestinians come in they may never go
home so Palestinians are effectively
trapped in this small rectangle that is
turning more and more into a war zone
Joe Biden swooped in and made a deal
with Egypt to let humanitarian Aid come
in through this Southern border but
there's still no news on whether or not
the Palestinians will be able to leave
and that is a big question for these 2
million people living in Gaza if you
want to better understand global
politics follow them for more